season two
we were both young when I first saw you
I say let's go to my room okay I really
like that idea let's go let's go
actually I'm so glad we're finding this
out in the moment I've literally never
seen that before
sorry guys I was just telling them a
joke hello E.T welcome to the common
room
[Music]
I really feel like we could have a
positive living experience together I am
Bella Malhotra AKA amruth core these are
Leighton and Whitney they're actors but
real humans as well was that weird no I
wasn't really listening
so this is where we cook coffee and
cereal which is fake
this was last year smelly fridge gag
what does it smell oh did one of you
like in the fridge which I was not
responsible for me that's racist somehow
we have a remote control for a TV that
doesn't exist I wonder if it's that
mirror if anyone has any hints please
please let us know and this of course is
the most important
part of the room right Seth I love your
Seth Meyers poster thanks yeah he's sort
of my dream guy it's like I want to have
sex with him
I also want to be him
[Music]
I just have to go get my ring
[Applause]
you get the chance to come back and do
it again and see familiar faces and like
do something that we care about yeah
yeah I think the writing's even better
this season yeah the comedy's even
better so if you like laughing prepare
to laugh well did you ask him if she was
seeing other people uh no are you crazy
you don't ask Guys these things you ask
everyone else you know
welcome to Sips I'm gonna show you
around my workspace I'm really excited
to be working at sips with you guys I
I'm sure we'll have a latte fun
so this is the the sitting area where
all the students sit here we have some
lovely little food that looks real so
that's the important part and on the day
when we're shooting our amazing props
team usually does substitute a lot of
this food for actual food
um which they are learning is dangerous
because when I'm hungry I eat the prop
food sorry can I order excuse me we're
gabbing here
okay I can show you this amazing
espresso machine that we have never used
but it is real oh this is I like this
this is like a little vintage Cola
um
machine so what brings you in did you
want to drink or a cafe Olay I work at a
coffee shop that looked very similar to
this actually
um when I was in college and did a lot
of the things that Kimberly does like
wiping down the tops here had to do that
in the past so I'm pretty good at that
you'll see Kimberly wiping down this
stuff a lot this will sometimes change
our board you know what could be so cute
is if we did Little Talk drawings that
changed every day it just makes it
really feel like it's a real place they
revoked my scholarship
so
I have to find an extra twenty three
thousand dollars a semester we left last
year I think at a lot of like really
intense Cliffhangers so you'll see those
sort of like dealt with and wrapped up
I've never seen this many hot shirtless
men in one place Bella goes deeper in
the objectification so I want to date a
guy with sick rip tasty abs like
zaka from Baywatch apps I think that's a
coping mechanism for her I think
Kimberly has like a newfound confidence
that definitely didn't exist in season
one if you need extra money you should
sell feed picks on the dark web that's
certainly an interesting idea Kimberly
no she spends the season like exploring
that confidence and kind of pushing the
boundaries and limits of what it is to
grow into that oh my God
foreign
first time I was like I don't know
what's going on there's still some I
don't know what's going on for sure but
there's a little bit more like yeah
we're here we're doing it yeah I think
it's at least like for for Leighton it's
very um
empowering even to a fault sometimes
it's my turn to catch up how many girls
are you talking to 30 like it just kind
of goes all over the place in the best
way we better party while we can
oh hello E.T sorry let me just put my my
book down I was such an intellectual
just doing a bit of reading in my room
why don't you step inside I'll give you
a little bit of a tour ignore them they
just they always hang out in here it's
the best place in the dorm to be
[Music]
over here this is my this is my dresser
this is where I supposedly get ready
never opened it once this is Kimberly's
desk what is she studying she's studying
um Fringe things
right we were above the young when I
first saw you so she's a huge Swifty
Kimberly is
um as you can see by the poster yes this
is her little corner this is her bed
that's Penny the panda which we did see
first season and in a setting I wasn't
too fond of but it's fine it's weird
having sex in your co-worker's room her
stuffed panda is is staring at me that's
that's Penny's name oh
gotten to my desk the best place to be
where I do a lot of studying this season
as you'll see I'm an intellectual like I
said before now this is actually kind of
a funny thing so first season they asked
me to send them pictures from me like my
childhood growing up so they could put
them on the set I showed up and they had
so many pictures of me off the wall and
I was like guys we didn't need to we
didn't need to do all of this but um so
yeah these are all my friends from home
and now they're in the show and on the
wall which I think is really sweet
um anyway also this is my uh bed which
is being occupied right now by people
that I don't I don't know why you're
here in my room
um but yeah that's that's our dorm it's
pretty quiet it's pretty cute and pretty
sweet I think we better check out
leighton's room what do you say
I said let's go to my room Welcome to My
Crib you've saved the best for last come
on in let's see what we find
[Music]
okay so if we want to gesture to the
left on the wall are actually things
that I like and I see that they get
switched out quite a bit then also we
have my initials which actually I'm so
glad we're finding this out in the
moment I've literally never seen that
before
so it must be new okay we literally met
like three days ago I don't even
remember your last name and then if you
want to follow me over here to my desk
I'm super studious super studious and
it's really important to me math is like
just everything if you follow me over to
this side of the room
now over here I have some really deep
questions
first question I'm right
uh
what the [ __ ] is that fish pillow
my first kiss
was with a fish
I am so glad we know that now so that's
my room tour and love you so much xoxo
hey guys we really gotta go get back to
set and Mommy has to keep vlogging so uh
we love you so much slay ET do you guys
have any final words
play easy May the force be with you
right amen
cut
[Music]